you
Green's cuts up his uncle Joey reporting
to you live from the Garden of Good and
Evil
which Thursday sling and dick and given
our [ __ ] and cheese crackers is what
your [ __ ] motto is today you
understand you ain't got time to [ __ ]
around your got time to do dick I don't
give a [ __ ] about the Dodgers I don't
give a [ __ ] about the car you'll [ __ ]
about nothing
you gotta walk them pick up an envelope
bitch-slap [ __ ] cuz today is
your lucky day [ __ ] uncle Joey
here reporting live to you the man of
many reefers we got some flow we got
some [ __ ] don't Romo cool number four
seeing the devil for the fourth time
today on Sam
to them NBC more feeling good looking
good Billy Ray I got a couple things
cracking today my back still on the
[ __ ] fritz but it's getting better by
the day and a little work out yesterday
a little work out the day before that I
just take it nice and easy put some
blood put some [ __ ] up cat composes
and some [ __ ] light squash you know
uncle Joey know I'm always on top mind
game I'm trying every day I gotta be a
little [ __ ] benefit I'm saying you
guys keep me in check but Joey enough
with the [ __ ] hippie let's park that
gorilla glue if it is like I said I'm
just taking a week off this week like a
normal human being family the kid you
know the farmers market [ __ ] like that
getting ready for Halloween weekend next
weekend I'll be in Vegas Friday and
Saturday my man [ __ ] Steve
Simone and South Pointe casino oh [ __ ]
then we're taking the party up to be
town beet town [ __ ] the will Bettina
November 11 and then 12 I'm at the
Foxwoods
it's UFC 205 belugas oh [ __ ] it's uncle
Joey and Connecticut that's all that
[ __ ] matters you understand him
besides that we're just sitting here
smoking a little bit I'm getting I just
talking to you [ __ ]
I love it
we get to smoke a little reefer in the
morning and that's a little [ __ ]
patois here de you follow me and beside
that that's it that's that the new
podcast is out which is me and Lea
talking about and trop alone and all
that type of [ __ ] and we'll be back
Sunday that's it man it's an easy no
[ __ ] drama week this the way your
life should be no [ __ ] drama nice and
easy a little writing a little smoking a
couple push-ups I'm sticking to my diet
and that's all that [ __ ] matters
MyFitnessPal calm 2,000 calories a day
that's it you know me I'm trying brother
every double every [ __ ] day I haven't
get better how to make you guys product
I'll make my daughter proud but most
importantly I'll [ __ ] make myself
proud you follow me without you guys I
got that with Joey
what's with the Abid let's keep sparking
this [ __ ]
I like it I like this operatory we have
it's gonna be about 100 [ __ ] degrees
here today starting to get hot already
like I said I got the [ __ ] chiral
part they're full I gotta I got a
conference call it - I gotta meet some
dude about a dog at 12:30 so my day is
complete tonight I'm with the [ __ ]
family I'm gonna go over to the food
trucks look at the bubbl mad pervert see
what he's up to haven't seen him in a
few [ __ ] weeks I've been on the road
on Thursday nights and that's it we're
gonna put this [ __ ] together I hope you
guys are well you know your uncle Joey
loves you
oh I love this [ __ ] gorilla glow mwah
I'm gonna be cross-eyed a little [ __ ]
Wow this would be the third bowl of
gorilla glue I have my protein shake
I had my almond milk smoothie with the
[ __ ] fruit about 6:15 you don't mean
no I'm trying that's all you could do I
listen it's it the [ __ ] that
you sit there and tap out the wife I
can't get it I had a lot of opportunity
to tap I don't know if I said [ __ ] it
you smoked a bowl you go out there you
give me the best you can [ __ ] be for
that day
don't worry about tomorrow don't worry
about next week but Thursday the 20th
time I swing they can be a savage but
for me to do that I think my [ __ ]
vitamin C I'm saying we gotta be right
we had to take a little medicine as my
friend used to say my trick up there new
one he used to say I gotta smoke my
medicine [ __ ] is bad this ain't no
medicine you won't you know me I'm an
insecure sack of [ __ ] they like to be
high so I get you know I can hide hide
from everybody except myself
I used ID for myself years ago place new
coke I used to get so paranoid I call
the cops on myself you understand I've
been there [ __ ] I've been there
so I don't come to me without a [ __ ]
okey-doke stories these [ __ ]
wanna come and uncle joy with his story
you gotta get up early early to in the
[ __ ] morning [ __ ] with me anyway
that's it and that's that
I gotta get a few white ticket you got a
right couple [ __ ] paragraphs in the
book and that's it my day will be
complete but it wasn't complete unless I
touch base with my [ __ ] family you
follow me that's a whirl about family on
a [ __ ] Thursday
all right time sucks I'm with you you're
with me and they want to be with us but
what we got is [ __ ] torture so they
could suck that dick and koala Shorty
and beside that that's it let's do what
are you doing with your life that's so
[ __ ] spectacular business you people
speakers are not working on to your own
little world like Chrissie Hynde and
[ __ ] birds-of-paradise pretenders to
tremendous album anyway that's it and
that's that boy you think I'm a matter I
move wrong boy who sad book capital he
said to wire we'll get to like puppet on
the boat hey there's a whole bunch of
the car with your mighty commissary
I'm a seeker mydlink and my mom a lot
big Natalia aya
Binda Tokyo so he was on PC Mac really
good oh you're American went on the
compiler anyway uncle Joey loves you
touched up to stay black and don't
forget about me